- Since you will all be touring together,
I have to ask, do any of you have like,
good luck rituals, like before,
do you have any, are you superstitious?
Any things you have to do
before you go on stage?
I'll start with Rona.
Let's start with Rona.
- Well, yeah, we do.
Before we go out, we look at each other,
we give each other a thumbs up and we say,
"Have fun with your friends."
- Oh, that's amazing!
I'm stealing that one, okay,
that's stolen.
- Well we stole it too.
- Okay, I was like,
"That is officially stolen."
- We were in Europe
when we first heard someone say that
and it was just, we were like,
"Oh no, that's it."
We're gonna have fun with our friends.
- Yeah, 'cause no matter what going
on in life or anything,
it's just alright,
yeah that's nice, I love that.
Do y'all have any?
- We have a bunch of individual rituals,
but I think we get together
in a little huddle,
similar to the ladies,
but Danny will always say,
what do you say, Danny?
- It varies, I mean, I
usually tell the guys
- What do you mean, you
say I love you guys.
- Yeah, I say I love you guys, and.
- You're the emotional
one, I love you Danny.
- No I'm not, I'm not.
- I love you guys.
- Yes.
- And then we all put our mics to Joey,
and Joey will give us usually one word,
one word of inspiration,
and it could be anything
pertaining to anything.
- Yeah.
- I love the words that just
popped in my head that I was
hoping you'd say, but I can't say now.
- Tell me, it'll be opening
night at the Mixtape Tour
- Just random, just,
yeah I'm not gonna do it.
- Yeah.
- So not classy.
What about you, Rick?
You have anything you do before show,
do you Rick roll yourself.
- Oh yeah, baby.
We, we definitely, we, I, we,
my band, my crew and everybody,
we get together, we have a shot of Jager.
- Oh, wow.
- Okay, yeah.
Bringing the rock and roll
to Mixtape Tour, alright.
- And then, and then,
I'm going to curse a little on here now,
So if there's any children watching,
cover their ears.
- Earmuffs.
- And we look each other in the eye
and we say,
oh my God, that was strong.
And we say,
have a good (Beep) show,
and the reason we do that
is because because I don't want anybody
to ever walk on the stage
thinking that we've got this.
I like everybody including
me to walk up there thinking
we've got to work for this.
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah
- Yes
- In someone's mind they go.
- Yeah
- Yeah man
- And then it breaks the nerves down.
I usually look at one of my band members
and be like
"Lester don't (Beep) this up for us"
- That's usually what I do.
- You're welcome.
I like to be as supportive as possible.